on their last two franchises I believe
they are building their greatest game
yet let's take a look at quantum break
xbox one exclusive the number one killer
is time destroys us all when Paul came
back he came at wrong older changed
he took away the only person who could
stop the end of time will my brother
Paul's men from monitor trying to stop
me thing is what time broke and changed
Paul it changed me too
time skipping it's getting stuck
cotton violent loops it's getting worse
everyone freezes except me
Mara has tapped to keep going with time
reeks
Paul knew this was coming he's not
trying to stop it maybe even made this
happen this could have all been avoided
well
Will's here
even when he's gone a puzzle trapped in
broken time universes a singing Aria
they should be no astir disabled no nada
glimpses in the first prototype time
machine the origin of time travel well
past its to the vendor horizon this is
impossible
something went horribly wrong here but
it's scrambled impossible the cracks
come with me gets fired mr. together
give me the device don't do it don't
what if
[Music]
please welcome from remedy creative
director Sam Lee
hello get some want a break is the next
big step on remedies 20 year journey of
crafting cinematic storage Riven action
games in contemplate two different
elements the game and an in-game
live-action show are fused together to
form an entertainment experience that's
more than the sum of its parts here with
me today is Hollywood actor and one of
the x-men Shawn Ashmore thank you Sam
thrilled to be here